Cloud security posture management versus
data security posture management two
different Focus areas that go hand
inhand with each other to making sure
that your information and your systems
are safe now in previous videos we went
over what are cspm and dspm but in this
video we'll do a really brief overview
on the differences between the two so
you can better figure out how you need
to cover your assets all right so in
this video we'll go over what do they
each
protect and how do they do it
and to explain this I'll use this
example architecture diagram here we'll
have multiple types of
servers and multiple
databases and then an important piece is
that it's all hosted on cloud
environments these purple ones are
public Cloud environments and these blue
ones are going to be private Cloud
environments so starting out with what
do they eat each protect now cspm
Solutions are limited to public Cloud
environments and do not cover the data
level protection so things like IAS and
PAs infrastructure and platform security
configurations and then dspm Solutions
do cover the data level protection and
on top of that they cover multiple
different Cloud environments so looking
at protecting your data for different
Cloud providers SAS applications and
even Shadow data that's not specifically
identified in your official inventory
next let's talk about how do they do
that well cspm Solutions are limited to
the public cloud and look at the
infrastructure and platform level
security so things like identity and
configuration management but then also
things like network security as
well and this is finding problems and
remediating them for things like open
port reports or exposed data stores
however dsbm looks at the data across
multiple Cloud environments giving you
the security and the visibility of your
data wherever it may reside so
remediating vulnerabilities for things
like unauthorized access or data privacy
non-compliance having a poor security
posture can lead to a lot of bad
consequences like having an exposed
attack surface unauthorized access loss
of money and even a damaged reputation
even worse consquences to that would be
like a data breach lawsuits higher
insurance premiums and even data privacy
non-compliance fines all which carry a
hefty toll on your business so if you're
going to take away anything from this
video know that when you're working with
cspm and dspm it's not an either or it's
both thanks for watching before you
leave please remember to hit like And
subscribe